on a multiple-choice test problem one
has four choices and problem two has
three choices that should be choices
each problem has only one correct answer
what is the probability of randomly
guessing the correct answer on both
problems now the probability of guessing
the correct answer on each problem these
are independent events
so let's write this down the probability
of correct correct on on problem on
number one on problem number one is
independent or let me write it this way
probability of correct on number one and
probability and probability of correct
on number two on problem two are
independent are independent are
independent which means that the outcome
of one of the events of guessing on the
first on the first problem isn't going
to affect the probability of guessing
correctly on the second problem
independent independent events so the
combined the probability of guessing on
both of them so that means that the
probability that the probability of
being correct on guessing correct on one
and number two is going to be equal to
the product of these probabilities and
we're going to see why that is visually
in a second which is going to be the
probability of correct on number one
times the probability the probability of
being correct on number two now what are
the what are each of these probabilities
on number one there are four choices
there are four possible outcomes and
only one of them is going to be correct
each one only has one correct answer so
the probability of being correct on
problem one is one-fourth and then the
probability of being correct on problem
number two not problem number two has
three choices so there's three possible
outcomes and there's only one correct
one so only one of them are correct so
probability of correct on number two is
one-third probability of guessing
correcto number one is 1/4 the
probability of doing on both of them on
both of them is going to be its product
so it's going to be equal to 1/4 times
1/3 is is 1/12 now to see kind of
visually why this makes sense let's draw
a little chart here and we did a similar
thing for when we thought about when we
thought about rolling two separate dice
so let's think about problem number one
problem number one has four choices only
one of which is correct
so let's write so it has four choices so
it has one let's write incorrect choice
one incorrect choice two incorrect
choice three and then it has the correct
choice over there so those are the four
choices they're not going to necessarily
be in that order on the exam but we can
just list them in this order now problem
number two problem number two has three
choices only one of which is correct so
problem number two has incorrect choice
one incorrect choice two and then let's
say the third choice is corrected that's
not necessary in that order but we know
it has to incorrect and one correct
choices now what are all of the
different possible outcomes we can draw
a little bit of a grid here you can draw
a grid here all of these possible
outcomes let's draw all of the outcomes
each of these cells or each of these
boxes in a grid our possible outcome you
could you're just guessing your randomly
choosing one of these for your randomly
choosing one of these four so you might
get incorrect choice one and incorrect
choice one in in incorrect choice in
problem number one and then incorrect
choice in problem number two that would
be that cell right there maybe you get
this maybe you get problem number one
correct
but you get incorrect choice number two
and problem number two so these would
represent all of the possible outcomes
when you guess on each problem and which
of these outcomes represent getting
correct on both well getting correct on
both is only this one correct on choice
one and correct on choice on problem
number two and so that's one pot one of
the possible outcomes and how many total
outcomes are there there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 out of 12 possible outcomes
or
these are independent events you can
multiply you see that there are 12
outcomes because there's 12 possible
outcomes so there's four possible
outcomes for problem number one times
the three possible outcomes for problem
number two and that's also where you get
a 12